today on our show hong homecoming
Hellboy 3 H is the only H's that matter
today on fat man on Batman
that men on Batman we do come into fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard okay folks true h mark promised
you three H's idea here's the first of
three ages no han Solo
for those of you who had your head up
your ass for the last year they may get
a solo on solo movie young Han Solo yes
there been some drama how to pair of
great directors on it not anymore
I got you on the door now got another
great director on it Ron Howard three
great directors bringing you one young
Han Solo and it's a fourth H Howard
Howard it's all h's alright so what's
going on with this young Hans oh uh they
they had a new member to the cast they
added a young Brit - I think promising
future ahead of him Paul Bettany
oh I've seen him in things so far that
dude's got vision he's got a vision he's
been in - Ron Howard pictures before
this name them beautiful mind you're
right yeah and the name of that racing
Brown no the Dan Brown across the world
DaVinci oh that's right he's whipping
himself that's right yes I am to be with
Kevin mark all right so Paul Bettany's
joined the cast of a movie that at first
was two weeks away from wrapping yes and
is now extensively reshooting
you'd like almost a whole other movie
yes sounds like mmm and adding a whole
new characters whole cloth there was one
guy that cut out of the movie yeah the
dude Omar Omar's going Oh mark coming no
more not so much anymore he's staying
alone Michael Kay Williams killed Kay
Williams was in the Han Solo movie and
then with the reshoots they asked him to
come back and he couldn't do because
he's committed to something huge he's
got another job so they had to they're
Xing him out of the movie not in a
shitty way but just like well it can't
continue that story so they're adding
substantial elements yeah it is not just
like I'm finishing our production it's
this movie was off the rails that we
wanted it to be on it honestly I mean
look I don't know and I don't know [ __ ]
from [ __ ] but from the outside it smells
like they're just making a whole
different
doesn't you know and now for another but
I think so is Jeff Sweden on let's talk
about that real quick as well
yeah the root the rumors out of the
Justice League shoot is that initially
it was like inserts and like hand shots
a little bit but now reports are coming
out that like about a half an hour of
news yeah but aside from what whatever
we've seen in the trailer and we all
know the trailer game doesn't mean if
they show it to you it's necessarily in
the movie anymore yeah it sounds like
they're making a whole different movie
to I mean I think as I already wildly
fallacious so don't mind me I think that
Joss Whedon is gonna get screenplay
credit
are you kidding yeah like I think that
came down the pike let's just put a pin
in this real quick just to talk about
the sidebar ladies a just said but do
you know how hard it is to get
screenplay credit at the second
screenwriter on any screenplay display
this to us I've gone through I've gone
through we're guild members writers
guild members and I remember there is a
picture called overnight delivery that I
rewrote back in 95 96 page one rewrite
changed everything not just names but
like all the situations kept the central
thesis God breaks up with his girlfriend
Express has to chase across country to
stop it from happening and stuff other
than that everything [ __ ] change and I
did not get credit on this good at all
if you ever watch overnight delivery
with Paul Rudd and reason Witherspoon it
sounds like a Kevin Smith movie but my
name is nowhere to be found on it they
asked me to do the arbitration they do a
thing called arbitration where they let
other readers read every draft of the
script they asked me to arbitrate
ant-man hmm when they were doing that
because there were a couple writers on
that and I had to recuse myself because
I'm like I know what to write
like I'm just over a girl right and
stuff they look good thanks for being
honest
so it's a hard core process to even get
added to the [ __ ] script let alone
replace the previous writer now the
previous writer of the script was the
guy that wrote Argo right right Chris
Terrio and he also wrote Batman V
Superman you're saying that Joss Whedon
will get scream like I mean here's
here's if I had to guess what might be
happening it's that he can't
get co-direct and credit well I don't
think the guilt has co-directing credits
you don't have to change the rules
because this is gonna happen more and
more with the success of rogue one
studios are gonna be like look we don't
have to settle for this we'll go back
and we'll spend another [ __ ] hundred
million bucks because you know what if
we get it right we're making a billion
so it's worth though it's this is penny
being Pennywise pound-foolish is stupid
in for a penny in for [ __ ] behind
like I see a lot more of this the guilds
getting DGA he's gonna have to figure
out how to do this this - director yeah
I mean I think there was an issue on sin
city that Frank Miller couldn't get
co-director because they were buddies
and they were that was they wanted to
get it together so they had to pull it
out of the yeah I don't think was a
union show at the end of the day because
they wanted a co-director credit he if I
remember correctly Robert for the
further one of many times quit the DGA
yeah so that he could do what he wanted
and I think that with tchotchkes and the
Hughes siblings because they're only
doing one name they get a somewhat pass
but the Coen brothers don't do it even
though they both like co-write
co-director coda right yeah once a
producer ones are one they're both
writers one's a producer wants a
director but the way I understand it
yeah they you just call they do all
three jobs so if they couldn't get a
code directing credit and it's not
siblings that it's entirely possible
that they came to an arrangement with
Warner Brothers and said we are going to
do this well again I come to that
arrangement with the original writer
though I mean it would be like you know
what my name is Paul is between y'all
y'all paid me handsomely I'll get a
story credit it's fine
and he would have to be doing crazy
substant he have to rewrite I think it
was like 651 60 percent of the point is
some ridiculous number like 60 let's say
50 to 60 percent of it has to be
completely new material from what they
shot in order for him to get credit
that's the case if he gets credit I
heard us say that this movie looks a lot
different when you see it than what it
was supposed to look like originally
yeah so anyway that's happening so who
knows exactly how Ron Howard will be
credited point is Paul Bettany might
wind up in justice league because Wow
for all you know hey why couldn't vision
just cross over he could be the man it
walks between every word Paul Bettany is
the fixer when your [ __ ] broke
you bring in Bettany and Bettany's the
patch that makes it go
maybe Bettany is what justice to go
along it's like Winston wolf of genre
movies I sat next to him on the couch at
walking to I'm talking dead and I said
something that made him like laugh so
hard I felt so proud he's an actor he's
been around funny people and [ __ ] like
that
like I just backed it with Robert Downey
jr. who to me looks like one of the
funniest [ __ ] people in the world
like you know III would [ __ ] if they
did an auction what I found out I was
sick and they're like what's your
make-a-wish I feel like I want to hang
out with Robert Downey jr. guys so you
know Paul Bettany hanging out with our
DJ making and I made him laugh for a
moment I felt like our DJ nice job
pretty cool Paul Bettany good to be in
han Solo is indeed what's he gonna play
maybe he's gonna play Crimson Jack that
rabbit from the comic books that'd be
amazing could you imagine if you're
reading it they like oh holy [ __ ] it's
the [ __ ] bunny from the Star Wars
comic that happened after the
novelization of the movie Paul you're a
very handsome man you you look you don't
look British at all how would you like
to I don't know be another voice in
something be a space rabbit come on
wouldn't be great I mean look what
happened to space racoon dude he's doing
great
might be like let's take a little rocket
in this wasn't a rabbit at least comic
books at one we need space marsupials
whoa who else we got to get my kid she's
like Paul Bettany splaying a bunny I'm
going that's the second age Sony's
bringing the homecoming writing squad
back together good because I love that
movie yes one of the highlights my
summer was spider-man homecoming yours
yeah can't wait to own it on home video
currently own guardians the galaxy vol 2
have watched it and cried now I could
just skip right to the Ravagers funeral
and watch Sean Gunn scream and [ __ ]
it's so I look forward to by its
apartment yeah so Chris McKenna Eric
summers are gonna be back in the spiders
we're writers
those that there's those like five
writers and they created on that
folks that wrote like I seen their names
a lot on Avengers movies they did the
last two civil wars Oh McFeely yeah
Marcus and look for Markus and McFeely
these [ __ ] guys are my like to my
favorite writers I'm like back in the
day you knew everybody knew all their
names this one came from this one these
two [ __ ] guys like came out of
nowhere they're fantastic came out of
nowhere the scripts are great their big
break was First Avenger but they've been
working for a shame there's no the first
Chris the Captain America the First
Avenger they wrote on that they wrote
all the Captain America movies and
because both of those dudes yeah they
have the credit screenwriters for all
three look I like all three of those but
those movies took a jump between one and
two like one is all origin and [ __ ] like
that the [ __ ] Captain America too and
[ __ ] Captain America three are
fantastic I mean I think it's once they
got into sync with the Russos and they
figured out we're gonna make all of
these movies a different movie totally
and not to take away from Joe Johnston
who was who did a phenomenal movie and
made one of the greatest comic book
movies ever made The Rocketeer it was
just you know origin I know all this
about cap but when they start doing new
adventures you're like right on right
[ __ ] and so once the Rousseau's got
dude finiti stuff let's do my favorite
writers on the planet I'm on this
[ __ ] show I think they're trapped in
Atlanta we talk about the Marvel
Universe but we're busy currently
building the mall but I met those news
in San Diego like three years ago I
think they were there for agent Carter
they were also having created agent
Carter the character for they were on
the show as well they were executive
uses the show super nice guys yeah
they'd be lovely good talk I like their
alliterative names Markus and McFeely
yeah which one do you want to make feel
Marcos yeah the writing teams coming
back John Watson two different guys what
are these cats names Chris McKenna and
Eric summers wasn't the director boy
part of it as well John Watts Yeah right
you got a writing credit as well and so
they're interviewed about the movie and
like sometimes you watch directors and
you're like what a blowhard this guy
like me a lot of people watch I watched
an interview but this guy was like he's
got a [ __ ] together like I like the [ __ ]
he said and smart guy I mean it's made
737 million dollars
so and what did the last Spider Man do
amazing spider-man 2 didn't do that
worse than 700 8 million worldwide
it's not like it was a flop by any
stretch imagine she's not this one
crushed it at the box that's interesting
it just nobody liked it yeah it's like a
Transformers movie and also everybody
goes but nobody nobody likes it now this
one what they got going for him is hey
at least now Spidey's part of the Marvel
Universe right that was the big tickets
and Tom Holland is absolutely coming
back for another one because he asked it
and Tom Hardy was coming for Veneman
yeah this time he's like for venom I'm
playing a 72 year old Polish woman
that's amazing I am I'm Tom Hardy and I
love my dog he had a dog she sees dog I
think it's dope passed away I don't know
and he put up this beautiful [ __ ] I'm
a dog guy put this beautiful thing to
his dog you love Tom Hardy anyway cuz
he's a genius actor this dog piece makes
you marry Tom Hardy good guy is it as
much as a Mary thing as when Chris Evans
did you see that bit with Chris Evans
got back from the set of The Avengers
after 10 months and it's dog all but
went to town on him yes yeah it's cute
I'm not a dog I love when a soldier
returns home even if it's a fake alright
last H last H Hellboy there is a Hellboy
movie coming lazy John McGee remote
datura has nothing to do with it that
don't matter that don't matter Mike
Mignola's has a credit on the screenplay
huge he's the guy created the character
the artist voted David Harbor is the new
Hellboy the guy from strange things the
adult from stranger things who wasn't
there was going to be a fella named an
edge screen in the movie the guy who was
Frances where's Francis from dead Depp
indeed we're supposed to be playing a
character named who also to be fair was
also in Game of Thrones
he was original Daario yes he was the
one that like killed the dudes and then
started hanging out
khaleesi but like next season he look
different yeah said we gotta recast this
guy it was a different dude but anyway
this guy this guy was supposed to be
playing a character named a major Ben
daimyo who was in the comic books is
Asian okay and so he's cast he was all
excited to do it so let's goes make a
Hellboy movie then when he found out
about the the origin of the character
and social media dead was social media
did which was you know sort of talked
about they said this is another
whitewashing is another example of
whitewashing what casting a white actor
to play a character that was originated
as Asian on the heels of Scarlett
Johansson engrossed in the shell and
then the heels of tilda swinton and dr.
strange it has been not even see it
cause celeb just some of the people are
more aware of than they'd ever been
before
right and so once he found out he
recused himself from the picture I know
I read this I know this from last week
but this is me acting what what and if
statement he said it's clear that
representing this character in a
culturally accurate way holds
significance for people and that to
neglect this responsibility would
continue a worrying tendency to obscure
ethnic minority stories and voices in
the arts I feel it's important to honor
and respect that therefore I've decided
to step down so this role can be cast
appropriately representation of ethnic
diversity is important especially to me
instead of a mixed heritage family it's
our responsibility to make moral
decisions and difficult times and to
give voice to inclusivity it is my hope
that one day these discussions will
become less necessary and that we can
help make equal representation in the
arts reality who is that that's a smart
dude
very smart dude man and also just like
wow what a right thing to do I saw I got
rewarded handsomely across the
Twittersphere the blogosphere a lot of
people go on like bizarre good for you
it I mean it's like it's putting your
money where your mouth is literally like
I don't know what his payday was gonna
be for that but it would have been
handsome yeah as a working actress I was
just like hey man like another job yeah
jobs are you know it seems sometimes
like oh everyone works constantly in
Hollywood that's because people string
together work and that's another
high-profile part for dude is like right
on man I'll build my resume and stuff
and now all the sudden he's like I'm not
gonna do it but he'll be rewarded
handsomely not just like you know by the
world gone good for you and better for
you know other people who maybe could
fill that role now but but you know
karmically speaking that's to come back
in a good way somebody somebody who
didn't consider him for something before
is gonna reconsider now going on it's
good guy totally you know especially
when you started looking at some of the
people who were doing the retweeting you
know they have a Duvernay in Jordan
Peele like a bunch of people at the
upper echelon of where Hollywood is and
we're Holly what's going oh that guy
yeah I like this guy now yeah so I can
remember that get some meetings let have
to say this was entirely mercenary no
not at all I think honestly I now know
the dude at all but what I read it
seemed literally the dude a little like
oh [ __ ] I didn't know yeah I'm a genuine
so I made a mistake I'll fix it before
there's a problem and I as Paul this
between y'all
indeed see ya good on him yeah man good
for him I liked him in that role of
course Francis so shitty you have to go
yeah I liked him as Dario to he seems to
be a good actor yeah those teeth a
little [ __ ] up yeah somebody just we
just lost our past excursions on the
radio is there like [ __ ] you mark
barnard and look at mark take that
straight would you like to come back to
the London Film at comic-con [ __ ] you
from the other half of fat man Batman
you all have a lovely teeth I've never
found the stereotype to be true lovely
folks smile it all day long there it is
folks for Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark barnard into missing off
an entire console [ __ ] aliens people
left an easy crazy
ah tune in next episode we'll talk about
less offensive things ain't that time
same fat channels podcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you